thanks to audible the world's leading
provider of audiobooks
for sponsoring this video deep
in eastern china's anhui province
situated
in a valley between the mountains is a
small town
called mao tanchang of the hundreds of
cities
and thousands of towns and villages in
the world's most populous country
mao tanchang is without a doubt the most
boring of them all unlike even the
drabbist of industrial mining or factory
towns
here there's nothing even resembling
entertainment
no bowling alleys theaters water parks
bars or internet cafes a game shop once
opened but was promptly forced to close
after locals led a boycott its busiest
places
a post office grocery store and a few
scattered restaurants
close early and stay quiet enough that
they could only be doing so
intentionally but make no mistake
mao tanchang is not a forgotten pit stop
slowly fading away to history actually
just the opposite thousands flock to
this four
000 person town hours away from any
major city
one with no historical or religious
significance
though there are no jobs to be had there
is a
factory some would argue though not the
kind you'd expect
its private high school is known across
china
as a so-called study factory where
parents bring their children to prepare
for the most important exam
of their lives its remote location
and lifeless streets are deliberate
features
there's simply nothing to do but study
as the town has grown in prominence its
population has doubled
from four to eight thousand the new
residents being the families of test
takers
who in turn drive real estate prices sky
high
and consume roughly 90 percent of the
local economy
the test is called the gao cow gao
meaning high as in higher education i.e
university and cow meaning exam
these days around 10 million third year
high school students
graduating seniors in the chinese
education system
take the test each year making it a
candidate for the largest
anywhere on earth in normal years the 9
hour
exam begins on june 7th and lasts
2 or 3 days depending on the province
although the exam is coordinated and
synced across the whole of china
excluding the special administrative
regions of hong kong and macau
the questions and logistics are arranged
by each province and provincial level
city
for most students it consists of math
chinese and a foreign language
usually english but alternatively
japanese
russian or french plus his or her choice
of either humanities
which includes geography history and
politics
or science meaning biology chemistry and
physics
the questions are mainly multiple choice
and short answers
though the chinese section includes an
essay scored by two random graders
before or afterward students list the
schools they wish to attend
by the time scores are released in july
provincial authorities have negotiated
their quota for admission to each
university
which determines its lowest accepted
score the maximum number of points is
750
though anything above even 700 is
considered
legendary thanks to its notoriously
inscrutable questions
when all is said and done around 10
percent of students
receive offers to one of the tier 1 best
schools in the country
and 20 percent end up in a second tier
school
the highest scores in each province
become overnight
celebrities their photos plastered
throughout their hometowns
parents praised on television and their
choice of school
subject to much scrutiny from a distance
the gao cow may seem like a larger and
slightly more elaborate version of the
s-a-t
a-c-t a-levels or j-e-e
but such an image would be wildly
mistaken
for starters the gao cow is only offered
once per year
meaning that if a student isn't accepted
into one of his or her selected schools
of which there can only be a few they
will have no choice but to wait until
the following june
which many do sometimes several times
over
to be precise only about 8 of the 10
million test takers are accepted
the other roughly 20 percent are faced
with a very
unenviable decision wait another 365
days
or give up parents often resent those
students who choose to take the exam
again saying they drive up the average
score at the expense of their child
sometimes despite already being accepted
to one or more schools
gao cow scores are also in most cases
the only criteria for college admission
the concept of recommendations
personal essays and extracurriculars are
so
foreign to chinese families that they
usually hire a counselor to guide them
through this process
when applying to an overseas university
the gao cow
is very much make or break which is why
it has spawned such a lucrative industry
of which mao tan chang is one of the
biggest benefactors
what sets it apart from all other
schools
tutoring centers and methods is that
quite simply
it really works it claims a 90
university admissions rate compared to
the 30 percent of its province as a
whole
of course this success comes at a price
and quite a steep one the campus is run
more like a military training academy
than a school with 16 hours of studying
scheduled per day
everything is designed and optimized for
studying
for example there are no laundry rooms
electrical
outlets or for many years even hot water
visitors including parents are allowed
on campus for exactly
three hours each sunday afternoon the
security guards who drive around on golf
carts
ensure these rules are followed its
real secret formula however is the way
it meticulously ranks
rewards and punishes its 500 teachers
alongside their students their salaries
are already higher than
average but what drives them to
essentially give up on their lives
quit their jobs hold off on starting a
family and move to the middle of nowhere
are the bonuses if a student is accepted
to china's famous
pe king or qinghua universities say
then 50 000 rmb or about 8 000
us dollars is divided between all of his
or her teachers
a good educator therefore can easily
double
or triple his or her salary on the flip
side
the lowest ranked teachers each year can
expect to be
fired to many people these descriptions
elicit pity if not outrage whenever
an image or anecdote of a six-foot pile
of books
or the school's 16-hour schedule goes
viral
a certain fury follows how dare someone
try to
pay to game a test or what an incredible
waste of young people's lives
in reality the vast majority of mao
tanchang students
are not rich kids from the city but
rather children of poor rural families
who have saved for years
for them the gao cow is a route their
only route to upward social mobility
and mao tanchang is their golden ticket
which is why when the day finally comes
it's one of hope and celebration not
dread or hatred
to an observer june 7th may look like
the beginning of a festival
parents book hotel rooms near the
testing venues
rows of buses full of students roam the
cities
escorted by a parade of their families
cars are forbidden from honking their
horns
construction sites within half a mile
are ordered to stay silent
and over 1 million supervisors across
the country
proctor at 7 000 exam sites
then on their final day after their
final stroke is written
students overwhelmingly report the same
unexpected feeling
loss while these nine fateful hours have
consumed nearly every second and thought
of the last few years of their lives
if not entire education the gao cow
also acts as a powerful goal a singular
milestone
far in the future and yet close enough
to always instill
urgency the gao cow is not a thing to be
romanticized
critics rightly emphasize the
unfathomable mental strain it places on
students
strain which sometimes spirals into
permanent damage
the years of lives it robs of every boy
and girl
the unnecessary rote memorization which
is never recalled
and the permanent destiny it prescribes
to those deemed unfit
but such an all-encompassing task also
provides a concrete purpose that drives
students forward
and a universally accepted excuse to all
failures non-academic one can be bad at
just about everything
and still be celebrated for scoring
highly
in some ways the gao cow is a mask
hiding all accomplishments and
challenges behind a single
person defining number and not only at
the level of the
individual social and economic
inequalities are also rationalized and
upheld by the meritocratic nature of the
gao cow
it suggests that everyone gets what he
or she deserves
providing an excuse for huge differences
and opportunity
and while there have been many moves to
reform the gao cow
and even discussions about replacing it
entirely
the great irony is that those who suffer
the most
families and students themselves are
also sometimes its most vocal
supporters to them the gao cow may be
the hardest test in china
but it's also their only ticket to a
better life
one of the inspirations for this video
was a book i read
called the case against education by
brian kaplan
it explains what so many of us think but
don't have the eloquent words to prove
how the modern education system fails us
you can listen to it just like i did
with today's sponsor
audible i've personally bought over 30
books on audible
and love the fact that once you choose a
book you can keep it forever
you can listen offline adjust the speed
and if for any reason decide you don't
like it
just exchange it for a new one in fact
here are the last few books i listen to
on audible
all of which i recommend and here's my
optimistic reading list for this
winter break with an audible membership
you get one free credit to download
any book in their collection every month
alongside
unlimited access to their plus catalog
of selected books
podcasts meditation programs and more
visit audible.com polymatter that's
p-o-l-y-m-a-t-t-e-r
or text polymatter to 500-500
that's 500-5
to get a 30-day trial and read your
first book
free today